my belief is like the three pieces of
scaling that i adhere to is zero to a
million is promotion one to ten million
is product
ten to a hundred is people right and you
can say well if you have the right
people you could yeah but that's not
typically how it actually happens right
so you have to know enough promotion
because if you have nothing then you
need to get people to find out right so
you have to start generating some
traction
once you get the traction and this is
where i think people mess up is they
they get their first dollar from
promoting and then think i need to spend
more dollars promoting the whole point
here is to get the product market fit
and make sure that the product is
exceptional and we're getting virality
from it people are sharing it we're
getting amazing reviews all of that
stuff is happening because then when we
go back to really scaling we're going to
get so much more return on every dollar
of advertising or media that we're
buying that it all makes the whole
machine work whereas most people then
try and dump more promotion on top of it
but the product isn't fixed